for people who don't know ezra just tell
us a little bit about her
ezra
in my opinion was an extraordinary human
being
she lived for 24 years
on this earth and i think that um
she touched so many people she lived
life to the full she was compassionate
warm
feisty fiery
she had a very very strong sense of
injustice she was my only child
in july 2020 police turned up here at
neveress kamal's home in north london to
explain that her daughter azra had died
in an accident falling from a bridge
over a year later more officers arrived
on her doorstep looking visibly
distressed
it reminded me of when
the two police officers arrived he told
me that as we had passed um there was
this anxiety and they had this level of
distress
i'm thinking i don't have any family
members so
why would they come at half eight they
said to me um
is to do with azra
and for that moment i'm thinking i said
to them what azra's dead
they explained that azra's body had been
raped by an electrician in tumbridge
wells hospital mortuary it would emerge
she was one of at least 80 victims he'd
raped azra hours before nevis visited
her daughter in the mortuary
what you're about to hear is distressing
i had spent
two wonderful wows in the mortuary
um
sleeping with her
and that gave me some sort of comfort
little did i know that my daughter had
been violated
prior to that day
and the evening of that day
so whilst i'm stroking my daughter's
hair
sleeping on her hair
a man had
crawled all over her skin
and there's me kissing and cuddling and
saying my last goodbyes
and that's quite awful
quite awful
however
it is not as a shame
it is not my shame
maybe some would just bury their heads
in the sand and
not want to know any more detail
but you've actively kind of sought out
the facts
you wanted to know
how long
yes when did he come in yes what access
did he have yes you've found all of that
out already and i tell you why jay jason
is that
if you allow for me personally if you
allow yourself to wonder what if what
happened how could it have happened
how long what did that person do
we spend a lot of time and energy
creating confusion and pain in your mind
for me to have facts i can focus on
those facts and i can focus my energy on
that
and i will never
bury my head in any sand
and nor would have azra i've thought
long and hard about this interview
and i know that ezra
would be asking me
tell the story
so you do have the detail and you do
know
the shocking thing seems to be that he
had
access
for 20 minutes half an hour well i'll
give you the details jason
the first time was 13 minutes
the second time was 15 minutes
and the day that i visited ezra and
spent quality time and my last time with
azra was for 35 minutes
to understand this neverest asked the
nhs trust for a map of the mortuary she
learned that david fuller had swipe card
access because he sometimes did
maintenance work there and that he knew
staff went home at 4 pm porters might
still visit the receiving area
delivering bodies but the same fridges
had doors opening onto the post-mortem
area where fuller committed his crimes
here there was no cctv until recently
and the fridge doors were unlocked
fuller gained access through the utility
rooms but he still passed cameras on
route and needed to swipe in
he had entered the morgan autopsy area
thousands of times not hundreds but
thousands of times
and no one
ever stopped him or asked
what's this guy doing in here he always
made himself available to the mortuary
staff
they thought that the perpetrator was a
great guy
and basically
he groomed them
he groomed them
they became compliant they never
questioned him you've met some of those
staff when he went to see azeroth yes i
did and very very good staff
but uh
you could argue that who would think
that someone would do such a thing
however
we have swipe cards and cameras for a
reason there was no logs about what he
was doing in there there was no logs of
how many times he was going in there
he would actually abuse women while
supporters were bringing in dead bodies
after fuller pleaded guilty to double
murder and the details of his mortuary
crimes were revealed the chief executive
of maidstone and tunbridge wells nhs
trust made this statement good afternoon
i want to say on behalf of the trust how
shocked and appalled i am by the
criminal activity by david fuller in our
hospital mortuary that has been revealed
in court this week
and most importantly i want to apologize
to the families of the victims of these
terrible crimes will you retire
in a meeting in october never has told
miles scott he should resign i said to
him
if you're really
truly sorry
surely
you will take responsibility
and step down
neverest traveled to kent for fuller's
trial to hear how his mortuary victims
ranged in age from nine to a hundred
years old and that he also stood accused
of double murder
if it was his only crime fuller would
face a maximum of two years for what
he'd done to ezra neverest says she will
campaign to make legal guidance and
sentencing stronger if he wasn't facing
murder charges the sentencing for this
kind of offence probably in your view
pretty minor men and women up and down
the country will be appalled
by what they're listening to
what they've read about
and i remind them
that if this was your loved one
you would roar with rage
and i'm silently
roaring and i'm beseeching
people that make laws
to create a law
that this becomes an offence
and the appropriate sentencing is passed
down
and i trust the law in this country
and i trust the people
of this country
and i hope
they realize that they need to shout and
scream
and say we need to respect the dead
ezra was a friend of mine and helped me
produce some of my reports here at sky
news
and ezra i know is someone who when she
saw
domestic abuse for example or violence
towards women she would go over to the
guy who was doing that and kick them out
of the house yeah that that's uh
life stories of ezra with her voice yeah
so when she had a voice she really spoke
up for women absolutely
and people might say oh well
she was dead she doesn't know anything
about it and you're more of the victim
than she is how do you feel about that
because you're the one that lives with
it
my daughter was the victim and all those
98 people were victims
because i have respect for the dead
so they are victims
i have now i am the victim's mother
i've tried to protect azer all her life
and when she really was helpless
lying there still
being raped and abused
and couldn't scream out
couldn't call me
couldn't call the police
i will ensure
that her voice is heard
and justice if served
and that will be my mission
neverest believes the best tribute to
her daughter is for lessons to be
learned
the hospital trust has launched an
independent investigation into whether
anything more could have been done
jason farrell sky news